et notre invité aujourd'hui s'appelle
galia ackerman bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes notamment rédactrice en
chef de desk russie un nouveau site
d'informations en ligne consacré à
l'actualité russe galia ackerman et
emmanuel macron et donc à moscou
aujourd'hui pour tenter d'apaiser la
situation entre l'ukraine et la russie
le kremlin lui a déjà prévenu ce matin
qu'il n'y aurait pas de percée
aujourd'hui c'est une façon de dire à
emmanuel macron que que sa visite n'est
pas utile
non je crois que poutine n'a pas refusé
de rencontrer parce qu' il peut y avoir
d'autres sortes d'autres issues que
kylie qui permettre d'autres questions
qui peuvent être abordés mais sur le
dossier craignant
et c'est clair que pour la russie déjà
l'ukraine n'a pas droit de gérer son
propre sort parce que pour pour la
russie pour le régime de poutine plus
exactement
c'est un c'est tant pis la souveraineté
limitée c'est un nouveau terme qui est
utilisé maintenant et le sort de
l'ukraine qui pourtant se trouve au
centre de l'europe c'est un pays d'à peu
près un million d'habitants plus grand
que la france en territoire
donc ce n'est pas non plus vraiment à
l'europe de régler le sort de l'ukraine
parce que vladimir poutine se pense en
héritier de l'union soviétique et il
conçoit aujourd'hui l'époque depuis
longtemps révolue où en fait il y avait
deux grands états unis et l'union
soviétique
en tout ils ne s'en cachent pas ils
exigent des négociations d'ailleurs
d'égal à égal avec les états unis donc
la france n'a pas droit au chapitre
finalement
emmanuel macron essaie de faire en sorte
que la france est un mot à dire mais en
fait on utilise la france pour le format
normandie en fait la seule utilité que
peut avoir la france aux yeux de bénir
poutine c'est
de contraindre l'ukraine d'accepter les
clauses totalement inacceptable des
accords de minsk ce qui en fait
l'objectif du format normandie mais en
dehors de ce format et en dehors de
cette exigence russe qui probablement ne
va jamais aboutir en effet
il a ici n'a pas une très haute opinion
de la france elle n'a pas une très haute
opinion même de toute l'union européenne
et dans ce sens
ce qu' il est difficile de s'attendre à
un bilan vraiment positif de cette
négociation
ceci dit il ya maintenant plusieurs
dirigeants qui veut lundi à moscou le
le prochain ça va être donc le nouveau
chancelier allemand et c'est aussi un
moyen de faire traîner les choses tant
qu'on parle
il n'y a pas d'action et donc dans ce
sens
la visite de macron qui essaient de
faire en sorte que le temps passe et que
la russie repousse en attaque c'est déjà
du temps gagné voilà vous vous le disiez
des désaccords existent sur la
résolution de ce conflit dans l'est de
l'ukraine ce sont les accords de minsk 2
pourquoi ne sont ils pas appliqué
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui achoppe
bas ils sont pas appliquées parce que il
ya déjà des divergences
dans l'ordre de l'application de
différentes causes clauses de cet accord
les russes exige tout d'abord la tenue
des élections dans le dos net dans la
région de donetsk de lougansk
pour élire les nouvelles directions ces
deux républiques mais elle n'entend
absolument pas les autorités russes
qu'on puisse assurer la tenue des listes
de sélection démocratique c'est-à-dire
les élections où serait présente tous
les partis craignant et/ou en effet dans
la transparence
soit possible ça c'est le premier point
il l'ukraine refuse de
des négociations
auxquelles la partie ukrainienne ne sera
pas admise donc déjà c'est une grosse
pierre d'achoppement ensuite les accords
et disent que après ces élections la
nouvelle direction d'un public
aura un dea droit
de participer en tant que sujet de de la
fédération de l'ukraine parce qu'il est
aussi question de la fédéralisation de
l'ukraine qui aujourd'hui quand un état
unitaire
et donc les les élus de donetsk de
lougansk auront le droit de veto pour
n'importe quelle décision
allant dans le sens pro-européen de
l'ukraine donc pour le crâne c'est
clairement inacceptables et enfin le
dernier point le cren exige aussi dans
le cadre des accords de minsk de
récupérer le contrôle des frontières
et donc point que les gardes-frontière
le kenyan contrôles à la frontière entre
ces républiques autoproclamées et la
musique et bien sûr ni la mini-série
publics ne permettent pas
que cela se produise voyez donc c'est à
quoi font d'achèvement
galia ackerman et eu une dernière
question si vous le permettez selon le
renseignement américain la russie a déjà
70% du dispositif nécessaire à une
invasion à grande échelle de l'ukraine
kiev de son côté tente de relativiser ce
que les états unis dramatise la
situation selon vous où il y a vraiment
une menace un risque d'une invasion
d'ici à quinze jours par exemple
le risque est tout à fait réelle ceci
dit je pense que la dîmière poutine
probablement n'a pas encore décidé s'il
y aura ou non innervation pour l'instant
cette concentration de troupes et
d'équipements militaires
absolument inouïe aux frontières de
l'ukraine est un moyen pression parce
que si l'occident cède et aussi les pays
occidentaux l'otan et les états unis en
clair promettent solennellement que
jamais au grand jamais l'ukraine ne sera
admise à l'otan et où si on
réussit à impliquer les les apports de
minsk dans la perception de moscou c'est
à dire fait des réalisations de crème et
la possibilité pour les deux républiques
de bloquer n'importe quelle décision
pour européenne donc dans ce cas une
invasion ne sera pas nécessaire voyez
ils auront obtenu les russes ceux qui
veulent par des moyens de pression ceci
dit il ya un nouvel élément maintenant
il ya aussi l'annoncé
des manoeuvres en biélorussie avec
l'utilisation d'armes nucléaires
j'espère pas à pas les vraies armes en
mai mais une limitation que justement
mais cela est encore un moyen
d'intimidation sur l'allemande celle en
russie oui mais merci beaucoup galia
ackerman d'avoir été notre invité je
rappelle que vous êtes rédactrice en
chef de desk russie un nouveau site
d'informations en ligne sur la russie
merci merci à vous